welcome thanks for coming uh we're in a
special a different room today uh than
than the normal one uh so I'm not
exactly familiar with the technology of
this room but uh but I think uh this I
hope you'll find that the the material
is interesting enough that you'll get it
even if I even if I mess up on on some
of the presentation um welcome to the uh
uh 9th Annual Christmas tree lecture
every year about this time I try to uh
get everybody in the holiday Mood by or
or help anyway get people in the holiday
Mood by giving us a lecture uh about
trees uh one of the reasons being that
uh trees often associated with this time
of year and also U uh computer science
uh uh has trees as one of its uh Central
ideas and uh you know somehow we can
claim that we know more about trees than
a lot of dummies do and the na numbers
in
we get we got lots
of why do you want Fon ACI and Easter
for
rabbits good idea so so uh uh everyone
who works with computers uh uh knows
that we we can make Giant Steps if we
understand the small Concepts that we
that we deal with all the time and and
uh it's never I I don't think I'll ever
run out of uh of new things to say about
trees every year uh uh I have to select
between several topics that I might that
I might choose something that I learned
about trees during the year uh and this
year well I had I had two main ones that
uh that I chose between I hope you like
the one that I that I chose
um uh let's see what else uh is there by
way of introduction
um well if I forgot something I'll I'll
bring it in later uh now we got this uh
I asked Maggie my secretary to make have
a really nice bright red uh poster for
the book but that means you can't read
this that particular side but we're
we're going to try to use a combination
of uh of of me opening a book here and
and you seeing what's on the table and
me using overheads over here instead of
the way we we do when we're over in the
in the in our normal room um what I want
to talk about today is
called can you read it there no chains
of subsets
and um and uh this is an easy concept
everybody knows what subsets are and uh
so a chain of subsets there's a bunch of
subsets uh first subset second subset
third subset and so on I a sequence in
which each one is contained in uh the
ones that follow it uh so that's called
a chain properly contained in in it and
uh uh what I want to talk about today is
something that uh at least half a dozen
people have discovered independently
over the years and so and they they came
across this the same concept in in a
variety of different ways and that's
always a a sure uh clue that that
something important is involved in this
concept uh and um uh the first to
discovered as far as I know was uh uh
Professor de bruy and two of his
students in n and they published it in
1951 uh uh uh de Bry was my uh sort of
second thesis adviser after I got my PhD
every time I had a question I couldn't
solve I used to write him a letter and
then he would write back giving me a
hint on how I could how I could get
there uh now
um uh and and uh other people uh came up
with it in the' 60s and 70s and ' 80s
90s and uh this summer there was a brand
new application of it which I'm going to
get into today um uh the the but the um
the key explanation of of of why it's so
simple and nice uh was made by Curtis
green and Dan
kman uh in in the in the 70s um actually
when I announced this talk I didn't
realize that they had already discovered
the one of the things that I had that I
had uh uh noticed earlier this year when
I when I was looking at De Bruins paper
um but since I but since then i' I've
learned that you know it's a it's a idea
that comes over and over again so the
idea is we we want to take all the
possible sets of an N set all the
possible subsets there's two to the nend
of them and we want to arrange them into
chains uh that are disjoint so so we
want to put every set into into one of
the chains and and pretty soon you'll
see um you'll see what I mean in fact I
can show you one of the let's let me let
me try this uh aspect of Technology here
just to show you um one of
the examples so suppose we have for
example all subsets of whoops
wrong did that work okay can you read
that okay I hope I just made these
slides few minutes ago um
so all subsets of five elements we rep
represent by a bit string zeros and ones
and so it's one if it's if the guy's in
the set and zero If It Isn't So the so
if you go if you read to the right in
each line you're always adding one one
new element and all 32 elements are are
in there in one of those lines okay now
the total number of lines is uh
10 and uh uh well in fact uh uh you see
um it's also group so by the columns you
have all the things that have all the
subsets of zero elements one element two
elements three elements four five and so
on so uh uh if you have two subsets with
the same number of elements they
couldn't possibly be be in the same
chain so since we have 10 elements uh 10
subsets that have two elements in them
we got to have to have at least 10
chains if we're ever going to divide all
of these things into chains um and uh
and uh you can say well what what good
is it if uh uh uh if we can divide it
into chains and well that's a good
question I mean uh uh actually we didn't
used to have to answer that because we
used to say well it's beautiful so it's
so therefore it's useful but now we also
say well there's lots of reasons why you
might want to do it and that's why so
many people discovered it uh one is for
example um if if n is if the number of
elements is odd uh then the uh the
number of of ways to take U you know
let's say n is equal to to 2 N + 1 so
then then uh the number of ways to uh to
choose M of the elements just a little
less than have is um is the same as the
number of ways to choose M plus one of
the elements because uh choosing the the
M that
you that you're picking is the same as
choosing the N plus1 that you're not
picking so so there so and these are
this is the largest binomial coefficient
there's more of the of the cases in the
middle than in any other um in any other
place well now uh it's it's uh not too
hard to prove that there exists a way to
map all the choices of M things into the
choices of M plus1 things uh that makes
a matching so that every every M set has
is matched to an N plus1 set and and
those you you know and it exhausts so no
no two things are matched to the same
one uh and uh there was an easy way to
prove that algebraically that it exists
but but uh for a long time nobody knew
um uh any construction that would that
would actually show uh you know if if n
was a if M was a million how would you
write down you know saying what's the
what's the mate of of of the following
million set what's the what element you
add uh in order to in order to match it
and uh so uh this this method that I'm
going to talk about today gives a real
easy answer to that problem uh for every
every set we're going to be able to find
a natural set that it's that it's
contained in which we can sort of match
it with Okay so so uh uh for example
here we if you just look at the middle
columns here we've matched the the the
middle elements of the of of all
combinations of five things um another
thing is a very famous uh theorem of of
sperner goes back to the
20s um and uh it's it's been applied so
many times um it says if you have any
collection of sets whatsoever any
collection of substance whatsoever uh
and none of them is contained in any of
the other ones
uh uh this called a clutter by the way
it's got different names it's called
anti-chain but it's also called a
clutter um not the greatest word uh uh
to to say that you you know you spend
your research working on clutters but uh
uh but some people did and they prove
good theorems um so a clutter how many
how big can a clutter be how how many
sets can you have in which none is
contained in another and the answer uh
turns out to be easy be because of uh if
we know this chain decomposition because
if you have any two elements of a
clutter they have to be in different
rows so so the best we could possibly
get is 10 elements in a clutter and one
way to do it is to choose one of the
columns for example okay so these are
some of the simple simplest applications
of the of the of the idea and I'll go
into some more but but let me tell you
what the what rule is that that led to
this pattern it's uh that's so simple
because uh well it has to do with three
um
surprise get myself a
pen um
now
uh first thing
uh
that that I like about
trees inside a computer is that they
represent um matching
parentheses uh anybody here ever program
in lisp uh a few people know about
matching parenthesis okay so you have
left parenthesis right parenthesis and
if you if if you write down a bunch of
parenthesis are random uh uh let me just
uh let me just do it um suppose I do a
right right let me see actually I'm
going to I I haven't tried this before
but uh uh people whove heard me lecture
before know that I if I ever need a
random example I always go to the number
pi uh for for the example in fact I I I
uh I've been doing it so much now that I
in in the latest uh printings of the art
of computer programming you can look in
the index and you can and there's an
index entry for pi uses a random example
it tells you all the pages in which uh
in which that was that was done somehow
it always seems to you know it always
seems to be the uh
uh something that that works makes it
makes a good unbiased example um but not
to a random base not to a random base
but like if you say What's the most
interesting permutation of four elements
it's
3142 and almost always when you have a
conjecture about permutations if it's
false it'll fail for that one I don't
know why um now now I'm now I'm going to
give you another trick that wasn't
advertised in this in case you ever have
to know the value of pi in
binary um because uh because I've never
published this um but um uh but
uh here here it is I I I
know the octonal facts about Pi
now um uh what you do is you remember
this little phrase and you say most
people only know Pi in the decimal
number system but I I know the octonal
facts about pi and you shout the word no
because it means zero but otherwise you
count the number of letters so this is
31 1
0375 52 and so so now we write it as
three um uh one one and octal zero 3 7
five five I haven't worked one out in
HEX in HEX yet but this this is good
enough so now I'm going to write a right
parenthesis for every one and a left
parenthesis for every zero um just to
get a random example of parenthesis and
those of you who have who have some
experience with Lis will have an
advantage over the rest of us but not
too much
um okay now um one thing you can do as
everyone knows with parenthesis is match
them and uh now but
uh going back to why am I doing this is
because this is an example of a of a of
a random subset so I'm going to find out
which is you know which chain it belongs
to what are the things to its left and
its right in the chain
um of of all subsets that have that many
bits uh so start out and and you can
group The you can group the parentheses
okay so here's a group here you can
match these match these guys anytime
you you got a left followed by a right
you can match it and so effectively
remove it from the diagram so then you
then I can match larger
constructions um this one will match
maybe oops let's see here's one that's
going to match here this guy come up to
here uh this guy over here if I match
everything it's not going to be too
interesting but but that'll be another
interesting fact about
Pi uh okay here we go uh I think I'm
done I think everything left is
unmatched this guy is unmatched this
right princess is
unmatched um and uh this right princess
is unmatched this left parenthesis is
unmatched okay now in general if I if I
do this then I will have found little
regions of of matched stuff and and then
I'll have a few right parenthesis maybe
that are unmatched and a few left
parenthesis that are um uh that are
unmatched at the end but certainly all
the right all the unmatched right
parentheses have to start have to start
out so in general uh it'll some it'll
it'll have the form something like you
know Theta zero and a right parenthesis
es and then Theta 1 and a right
parenthesis and then sort of theta J
I'll say in a right parenthesis Theta J
+ 1 and a left
parenthesis and then finally we get you
know somehow Theta sub k
um uh where each of these thetas um is a
b balance thing in this example didn't
have have anything that matched uh at
the extreme left or extreme right but
that could happen but anyway in general
then parts of things will be unmatched
and then you'll have you know J
unmatched right parts of things will
balance and they and they form a unit
that uh that's a box that we don't have
to look inside and then there's these
unmatched things uh the right
parenthesis of J of them and left
parenthesis um K minus J of them and um
some times J is zero sometimes K is J
but in general it'll look like this and
what we do to find a successor is is
very simple we just change this left
parenthesis to right parenthesis you
know make one more
uh uh make one switch so Theta zero
everything else stays the
same
um and uh but but now we're going to
have lefts over in the rest of it so so
that's the rule that that it defines a
successor of every element uh and in the
previous slide when I showed you all the
all the chains for five five subsets
that was the that was the idea the one
the zeros and ones you you find a zero
followed by one you put a box around it
effectively remove it and then you look
for another zero followed by one you
keep on doing that until you uh you
can't do it anymore then everything in
the boxes is is called Theta something
something or other and you've got a few
zeros a a few ones maybe that haven't
been boxed and and a few zeros that
haven't been boxed uh so you check the
first zero that that hasn't been boxed
and changed it to a one uh if uh however
um there aren't any zeros that you know
all the zeros have been box then you're
at the end of the chain and if you want
to go to go backwards uh obviously you
just change one of the right parthis to
a left parenthesis and you keep on going
until until there are no right
parenthesis unmatched so that's the way
to uh to move around uh in this um in
this diagram so it it's a it's
equivalent to to many other ways of uh
of of developing the same uh chains but
uh it's nice because well one in one Cas
in one sense uh see every every way of
making uh of of of putting things into a
box uh corresponds to a uh to a tree
structure um uh for example if you have
a if you have parentheses that go like
this uh that's a that's a set of two of
of two formulas and and the left hand
formula has another one inside it and so
every you know so so I can this binary
tree uh or I mean sorry this tree
represents that formula if I had another
guy over here I could I could make
another one if I want to put another
parenthesis in here uh or two
parenthesis in there then I could that
would correspond to adding more legs to
the tree so so every there's a very
natural way to uh uh to associate uh
parenthesis Pairs and as an encoding of
of trees in fact uh you just walk along
this tree and every time you go down you
emit a left parenthesis and every time
you go up you emit a right parenthesis
you know and that and that gives you the
sequence of left and right parenthesis
so so uh uh that's one connection with
trees but there's there's another
connection which is even nicer um and
that is it's a new family of an infinite
family of of of of trees that um that I
hadn't seen before and uh and I think is
kind of pretty uh so in that namely that
the chain that we we have these chains
of
subsets um but the but they
also um the chains themselves form a
tree so so one chain can be considered
to be a child of of another chain and uh
let me uh let me show you the family of
trees and then relate that to to the
example but are there any questions
first of all on this basic rule if I
give you any any set of zeros and ones
you could figure out you know if it's at
the end of a chain or what guy goes to
its
right yep yeah yeah I'm B confused how
the rule Works can you show me how it
works for like left parentheses starting
and all
the
yeah how many do you how many rights do
you
want okay
so we match this guy that's Theta 0 then
this is Theta 1 is empty and Theta 2 so
so so this is this will now go into into
um uh I'm sorry this is the end of a
chain because there's no left
parenthesis okay all right so that's
0111 all right yeah uh and I'll and and
and uh no I showed you these examples um
so you could see uh uh if if you these
are chains on five elements but if you
just forget the uh you know all the ones
that end with one just forget they're
there and and uh you cross them out and
and drop the last guy then you've got
the the rule for
four so
0111 um
appears in the third last
row and no it it's at the end of a chain
yeah
okay all right there
now let me show you um another
construction that's that uh ties in with
this and this is this is something that
I I just learned
uh uh basically this morning so um let's
let's start to grow a family of trees
and we start out the first tree is
pretty simple I'm going to get my cheat
sheet if I can find
it
yeah first is pretty simple now the rule
to get to to the next stage is take it's
very simple you take every note and and
add a new child to it so there's only
one node so to get to the next step I
just add a new
child uh now uh this might seem like a
uh a very simple rule for for generating
trees in fact it it leads to to um
binomial trees if I don't modify the
rule a little bit but it's it's almost
it's almost the uh the rule that I that
I want so here I'm going to uh to get to
the next step I'm going to um uh uh just
add another child to each guy uh but
there's a new rule and that
is uh every second time I I I I don't
allow a child for the guys at the very
bottom level so here I'm only going to
get three instead of four so so so the
guy at the bottom level doesn't get a
chance to sprout
children uh and I only use that rule uh
half of the
time so the next time I I won't use the
rules so everybody gets a new child so I
start with this all three gets a new
child this guy gets a new one this one
gets a new one this one gets a new one
uh but at the next step I'm only going
to allow the the top four guys to to to
have new children and uh so I'm I'm I'm
only going to get uh 10 instead of
12 so here are the six that I start with
and uh and so I add one to this one to
this one to that one to that and I
should have 10 one two 3 four five 6 7 8
9 10 okay and that's
uh uh you know the next time I I'll have
20 uh because I don't use the Special
Rule and so there'll be a new guy here a
new guy here new guy here new guy there
guy here there there here there there
that should be 20 if I did it right
okay so now the the dots in these trees
represent chains in
my um example so if we go to chains five
uh this corresponds to the case here
where I had 10 um 10 noes in the tree
because there are 10
chains and uh
uh what you what you do is you imagine
that every Everything uh is a child of
the of the first one above it that's
bigger than it so so the guy at the top
is is this Grand chain here it has four
kids that those are the four kids are
the four uh chains of length four and
and uh you know uh actually we I drew
this from right to left so this is the
first the first CH the first uh chain
this is the second child and it has one
uh one below it so so it has this has
one child below it then the other two
children both have two kids as shown
here so so that's the
correspondence uh between uh between
this this family of trees and the the
other so so the binomial trees that have
have been used for lots and lots of
applications and priority cues and
things um
uh only use the first rule say saying
just add a new child to everybody at
each step but here we have this extra
extra hooker that says every second time
don't so so the number of nodes you have
is one 2 3 six 10 20 and the next time
it's going to be 35 because there are
five guys here who won't have kids and
this this is equal to the middle
binomial coefficient the number of
chains so this is five things taken two
at a time this is six things taken three
at a time this is seven things taken
three at a time and then we'll have 70
is eight things taken four at a time and
so on uh uh that's the number of nodes
in this way of growing a bunch of trees
so so here we have um a a rule by which
we not only have chains of subsets with
the various applications that I'll
describe but also those chains of
subsets uh themselves fit into a into
into a nice pre structure that has some
some uh
um some properties that we can that we
can explore um now uh in fact uh let me
try to explore the let me show you one
thing we can do with them and that is uh
instead of writing them as nodes let me
write them more as CH so that they look
a little more like
chains um and so um uh uh the rule then
is when a when a um uh
uh when when a chain uh so so here these
two guys actually represent two sets uh
that the straight line is is is what I
call the dot on the left hand side now
here I'm going to have two straight
lines because there are two dots over
here and um uh what happens is uh each
each line gains gains an element so the
two comes a three and also gets a new a
new child but the new child has one less
element so it turns out that this is
like this and uh I I and I can I I can
draw it this way so here's a chain of
length three and a chain of length
one now when I go to the next step I do
the same thing I start with this chain
of length three but I convert it to a
chain of length four and I put a chain
of length a new guy underneath a chain
of length two then this chain of length
one uh becomes a chain of length to and
uh that would also um get a chain of
length zero underneath the that's why we
left it out at that stage because can
you say that again yeah say that again
that yeah differently okay so so the
general rule the general rule is if I
have something that looks like
this uh it
becomes at the next step you know from
five it goes to
six and four underneath it like
that so so on the left hand side
I I said I had this
becomes this in other words every node
got a new a new a new kid here every
chain gets a new chain below it but but
it grows in length by one and the one
below it uh has shrunk by one and that's
why this funny rule comes along at the
at every other step because the because
the guys at the bottom have only one or
chains of length one in those in those
cases
and that's the and that's the uh uh
that's another way to give you the exact
same construction that I that I told you
about when they matching left and right
parentheses if you if you uh uh you know
you it's you you can look look and see
what the what the rule is but basically
if I have um uh uh you know more
complete uh notation in fact I want to
try a notation out on you guys and see
and see what you think because they if
it works I might use it in in volume
four um I always have to remove this
White Strip from the paper it drives me
up the wall when I see a lecture and
somebody uses overheads and remove the
White Strip now um here's
the idea uh suppose that I uh every
everything in the tree here has
a has a
successor um that has one element every
set has has a successor has one more
element this the successor if if you're
not at the end of a chain your successor
just means move to the right in the
chain but if you are at the end of the
chain it means move up to your parent
move up move up to the one who spawned
you and um and this gives everybody a
successor except except the all ones uh
uh vector and so I can I could use the
notation
Alpha um goes to the right
to Beta saying that this means that that
beta has one more element than Alpha and
Alpha like this
beta would mean that the same thing that
that Alpha has one less thing than beta
but there is going to be a there's going
to be a a successor uh everybody's going
to have a successor that that that
becomes one larger and predecessor and
so here's the the general rule um
flushing out what I said here in diagram
I can also I can also write it this way
suppose I have strings of of zeros and
ones alpha0 and Alpha 0 is the parent so
it's the predecessor of alpha 1 Alpha 1
is um uh is chained to Alpha 2 and then
let's say let's just give an example of
a chain of length four Alpha 3 um Alpha
4 um and then Alpha 4 goes to Alpha 5
which is the parent again so now this
will be a chain of length four four guys
uh everybody uh has you know alpha 1 has
Alpha 2 is successor Alpha 2 has Alpha 3
Alpha 3 has alpha4 a successor U and
their predecessors go this way but then
when you get to the end of the chain
Alpha 4 has a successor that's in a
different chain Alpha 5 and Alpha 5 does
not come back to Alpha 4 Alpha 5 has its
own predecessor and similarly Alpha zero
I don't know of any other notation that
would that Tech would handle that that
could that could
uh that could comp that that could
accomplish this kind of uh so so if this
is true then at the next stage what
happens is that Alpha 0 followed by0 is
now going to be the parent of alpha 1
followed by Z and that's going to be
chained to Alpha 2 followed
by0 uh Alpha 3 followed by0 Alpha 4
followed by
zero um and Al Al 4 followed by 1 and
then Alpha 5 followed by
1 um uh and the alpha zero will also be
no I'm sorry Alpha Arrow what what does
Arrow
Arrow that's this that's this upper half
Arrow okay Alpha 4 followed by one and
this is the half right arrow actually
it'll look much better if tech does it
um
uh that's why I wrote software but um uh
plan ahead uh I I want to write on
this um
so uh I will um this will all be clear
in a minute alpha 1
one
um Alpha 2 1 Alpha
31 and then up to here Alpha 4
now what I what I meant is I had a chain
before and I had the parents of the of
of the uh of the of of the guys at the
left and right they both hooked to a
chain of one of of length two more um
Alpha zero is the beginning of a chain
that ends at Alpha 5 and that's a parent
that that that comes to this one now
when I'm when I add a new bit then I
have to say what happens to the to the N
plus1 bit strings so I have to say say
what happens to all these things when I
when I put a zero or one after them and
the answer is the original chain stays
as it is I put zeros after it um know
those are left parenthesis they aren't
going to really matter in that other
rule I told you about uh and then I put
a right parenthesis then I put a one at
at the at the end so Alpha 4 Z so this
chain used to be of length four and now
it's of length five but the parent of
this of this chain is Alpha 51 which is
actually the the end of of of of a new
chain that started with Alpha Z Zer and
the
um uh and and then there's
another another new child um you know
this was a chain of length for so it's
supposed to get it's supposed to lead to
a chain of length five and a new child
of chain of length three and so here's
the chain of length
three by putting one after the first
three guys and that's the construction
that was used to get from from 5 to 6 so
here's
five and I swear that I did this with
emac macros um you I started with this
file and then I had a and I typed in a
you know one of the most interesting
emac keyboard macros I ever did in my
life which uh which did this little
operation changed each line into um you
know adding zeros or or ones and and
putting them on and and so it it goes
from this sequence where I have a you
know start out with a something of
length six and it becomes length seven
followed by a length five and uh and
generates the the set of uh of things on
six on six
elements
okay what is that with a regular
expression uh no no just a keyboard
macro you know you say uh meta F uh to
go to the next word and then uh you know
yes well no well I yeah you you can do
it several
times uh at the end and make sure that
that that that then you kill it I mean
you
I had to be a little tricky I learned
that trick from my wife but the uh but I
try to do it in Word Perfect I don't
know anyway uh it's another another
reason why emx is great so um
now uh and and uh you know if I had if I
had had that macro I could have you know
gone from chains four to chain to um up
to chains five and so on and and started
out with chains one and and uh and
gotten all these things going um and and
I'm sure that uh you know a great Java
applet will do this etc etc um but now
these are the chains and that's not the
end of the story um the one of the next
interesting things is that Paul erish
made a conjecture that you know he said
spern Lemma okay it's true you can't
have more than uh uh than 10 uh uh
subsets of a set of five elements that
that don't contain each other um uh and
in general for n you know you take the
middle binomial coefficient and that
bounds the the maximum number of of uh
sets that you could have that don't no
set containing another um but um but ER
said what if I had um elements that were
red and green and and I tried to uh uh
to find a lot of sets of these red and
green ones like maybe you have five red
and three green say um uh and the rule
is uh one set can contain
another set but the difference between
the two
sets uh has to has to involve both red
and green so so I I you know I can't get
from one set to another by adding a
whole adding a bunch of Reds I can't get
bunch of greens but but if I add a
mixture of the two that's okay so could
I get more sets then I'm allowing I'm
allowing two sets to to one set to
contain another as long as the
difference between the larger and the
smaller isn't the isn't the Pure
Color okay so so and the and er said he
didn't think that that would give you
any more flexibility that you still
couldn't get more than the middle
binomial coefficient um in the in in the
number and U that conjecture was proved
by Katona but it also comes out very
nicely out of this chains of subsets uh
thing and I want to explain
you explain that to you quickly um
without giving the whole the whole proof
Pro let's suppose for example that there
are um five um red ones and three and
three um green ones that's Christmas
colors uh so I'll get you a picture of
chains three what we do is we we um
arranged the the red elements in um in
in Chains and the and the green elements
in Chains but we consider the sort of a
a cross product of the of the two so I
can now get a bunch of um
so so um uh so all of the subsets of
eight
elements
uh uh all these 2 to the E ways of doing
it um I can actually do I can actually
um
uh uh think of like this I have um okay
there's so three
elements has a has a chain of length
four uh and it has also a chains of
length to I'm going to write those
vertically instead of horizontally but
now I'm going to also look at the five
elements that the five red elements and
there are chains of length six so
there's 1 2 3 4 five six and I can make
it you know this this kind of a grid
here um uh and then I then there's you
know there's other chain of length four
here so here's
4x4 and then the next one is another 4x4
and I I I don't have time to draw this
whole thing out but here's a 4X two um
and so uh you know in in general I could
I you know here I have a
2x6 and 2x4 and a 2x4 and a 2X two and
and so I I I get these
rectangles and the rule is uh so for
I've divided all the possible subsets
into into these rectangles right because
I I figure out which chain um uh which
red chain uh the set belongs to and
which green chain that's that belongs to
and that gives me um one of these
uh one of these uh you know uh the red
chain times the green chain if the red
chain has length four and the green
chain has length six then I get 24
elements that um that that belong to to
those respective chains and so now
what's the rule the rule is that um I'm
not allowed to have two sets from the
same row or column of any one of these
rectangles
so in this first rectangle I could have
at most four elements I could choose one
out of each row out of each row but you
know I can't choose any two in the same
column or anything and and here four
four here's two four and in general if
you got uh you know a k by L rectangle
you take the minimum of K&L and that's
as as many sets as you could have okay
so now what you do is you add
up um the the uh the sum over all these
rectangles of the minimum times you know
just add up all all the minimum so here
I'd be 4 plus 4 plus 4 plus 2 plus 4 and
so on and this would be 2 plus 2 plus 2
plus 2 plus 2 and add that all up and lo
and behold that gives you exactly the
middle binomial coefficient um and uh
and this was was
uh stated by by green and clan in their
paper uh with without proof uh in fact
they just seem to think it was obvious
and I'm I'm going to I'm going to write
to to
Curtis green tonight and say well can
you please tell me why it was obvious it
took me you know first of all I checked
it with Mathematica to make sure that I
wouldn't have to waste time and and sure
enough it was it was true for you know
Emin up to 10 um and then uh and so then
I said okay I better prove it and uh
there is a there is a fairly nice proof
but I I don't know an easy proof of that
but it's true um uh one thing we can do
though pretty easily is figure out what
these numbers are how many how many
chains there are of of of of each
length um so so that's uh that I claim
is a fairly easy question for example
here's here are our chains on five
elements how many uh chains are there of
length six um well you see we know the
total number has to be the binomial
coefficients at the bottom so this is
going to have to be 1 5 10 10 5
1 so the number of chains of length six
so so if I take the difference here I
get 1 4 5
0 um well these will just be the
negatives but um but so so there's got
to be just one chain of length uh six
and four chains of length four five
chains of length two it's the only way
that that can work
out so so the so so the answer is the
number of chains of length K is
something like M
choose uh nus
k/2 um minus the previous binomial
coefficient uh so because these are
these are the difference between two
consecutive consecutive binomial
coefficient okay is this clear you have
some questions equal or is it less it's
equal this is this this number in other
words let me let me go let me give you
the the binomial coefficients for 8 is
uh 8 choose 2 is um 28 8 CH 3 is um 56
isn't that 8 CH 3
* 8 2 3 8 * 7 * 6 over 6 yeah 8 * 7 is
56 and then 8 CH 4 is 70 as I said so so
so it'll say that in in the in the
um when I divide all the subsets of
eight elements
into uh into chain I'm going to have one
chain of length n seven chains of length
seven 20 chains of length five um
28 chains of length three and 14 chains
of length
one and that's going to you know that's
going to do it for and and now what you
do is you take these
numbers for M and you take the similar
numbers for
n and you multiply by the you know
that's so this tells you the number of
of of of of K by L rectangles you have
and you multiply so it's something like
the summation of AK a l minimum of K
andl and that turns out to be equal to m
+ n choose m + n /2 the middle binomial
coefficient and uh that um uh I would
love to see a really simple proof of of
this
because the A's are the A's are equal to
the the difference between you a sub one
is is things that are very near the
middle and a sub 2 is is is a difference
of two binomial coefficients just just
uh um just after that and so on um K and
L have to be both K has
to has to be congruent to one mod M if m
is even then K has to be odd and
and if m is um odd then K be even all
all these chains
uh the chain lengths are all are all
even or all odd depending on whether m
is odd or
even so so that's uh that's there are
other there are other um numerical
things that um that uh that check out
when you when you study this for example
I um if you take the um if you take the
power series C of Z equals z
plus uh Z Cub + 2
Z5 uh plus 5 Z 7th and you keep on going
U this these are the number of trees um
of binary of of trees 1 1 2 54 it's one
of my favorite sequences and C of z uh
and and uh if and so you you can use
this generating function and you can
figure out how many chains there are of
a given length because it's the number
of ways to to um to make balanced
formulas that that you're going to uh uh
that you're going to uh leave free
parentheses next to so for example C of
Z to
5th uh it turns out that c c of Z to the
5th uh if I looked at the coefficient of
Z the 2N + 1 in C of Z 5 it had to be
equal to I think it was 2 N / nus
2 - 2 N / n minus 3 this this just
turned out it had to be true because I I
knew how many chains there were um that
had five uh uh that had five balanced
formulas uh to be inserted in them and
uh and so I thought okay maybe this is a
new formula teach me something more
about this function C of z u but it
wasn't too hard to derive that from
other formulas I already knew so that
anyway it did check out of course
now um let me show you the the brand new
thing which came out uh this summer and
uh here we here
um uh I don't remember if it was Bill or
Bob but anyway you can shift now to the
overhead camera and I'll show
you I'll show you that that paper that I
just
downloaded um I press this off
maybe I press a little
harder yeah can we see
the show this paper so I I um uh the
paper by uh Jerry Griggs chip Killian uh
and Carla Savage I I downloaded from
Carla's website um and uh it says Vin
diagrams and symmetric chain
decompositions in the Jan lettuce so
they found uh uh some of the things I've
already told you were things I learned
by reading this paper U uh this this
idea of having all the chains put into a
tree um and they use this to make ven
diagrams now have you uh people know
what ven diagrams are this is something
that you learn in high school or at
least you used to uh so it's a u it's a
set of Curves uh uh you know and and so
you have three curves maybe and then if
you look at at the things that lie
inside of two of the curves A and B but
not in C that gives you one subset of
the set ABC and you're supposed to be
able to see all the subsets uh by by
looking at different different regions
uh where the curves
intersect um and uh there's also uh if
you if you go to the web
and and ask for Google let's see where
is my
i h didn't I bring
that oh that's a shame I had some
beautiful
pictures okay well I I don't seem to
have brought that maybe I maybe I have
one uh okay it's sitting in my office
too bad well
um type into Google uh symmetric Vin
diagram and it refers you to a page in
which there's some glorious pictures
of of V diagrams that uh uh that have
lots of interesting Symmetry and one of
the questions that was open was was is
there a symmetric Vin diagram for all
prime n where symmetric in the sense
that you divide uh if you rotate by by 1
over nth of the
um uh one over n of of a circle uh then
it repeats the pattern repeats again and
people had had uh
uh like Bronco grun Brown once published
saying that he didn't think you could do
it for n equal 7 and then 10 years later
he found a example for n equal 7 and
then now there's complete list of them
there six or seven ways to do it and
they're they're quite pretty pictures
and that's one of the applications in a
way of mathematics is where if you have
a nice picture to put on the wall um and
uh uh this in this in this paper they
they show how you can um do this for any
any Prime n you can you can use these
ideas about chain decompositions uh to
form V diagrams I'm just going to show
you uh a simpler uh a simpler thing that
relates to what I've been saying before
because it's cute too uh and it's the
it's the basic idea once you get this
basic idea then you're ready to uh to
see the other the other construction
which is very similar so so so what do
What relation could there be between
chains of subsets and V diagrams well
one thing of course is that we know that
every subset has to be one of the
regions of the vend diagram so what we
want to do is is is U um is make a v
diagram out of what we what we had
before and uh so I will try
this um and see if I get it
right um and so let me look for but let
me just do it with chains on four things
because that won't take so long so uh
back to the
overhead and I got to get the James 4 oh
boy this is not easy to
see okay
now now I'm going to take a blank slide
if I can find
one and I'm going to try to to to draw U
some curves so that you'll see that that
this would be a vend diag that this will
lead to a vend diagram so that there
will be so that these uh these four bit
codes here are going to be the the the
regions the um the areas inside the
inside the diagram maybe I maybe I won't
have enough
room um on this page to do it but uh
with luck with luck it'll work um but
maybe I should have made a bigger
example if so I can just recopy the DAR
thing let me let me recopy it because
then I then I know I'll have I'll have
room so 0 0 0 0 one so here you know
this basic chain is is the easy case
where
there's no
balanced no parenthesis cancelling at
all then there's the 0 0 0 1 one0 0 1 I
can see it better on the hard
copy one one 0
1 0 0 1 zero I should 10 10 okay 1011
01 so now the first step is we draw
the lines to predecessor and successor
which means that each chain we we draw a
line here
uh and then also to the parent so it's
the it's the closest person of one of of
size one less at the edge of these
chains so these are the the lines that
connect
everything um and this is as we said
before this is a tree this is the tree
we were talking about some few minutes
ago
now this diagram um has as many regions
as there are chains uh and I'm going to
put just going to put a circle here um
to to Mark the the middle of the
region I should have probably put that
on another sheet of paper but it's too
late
now me get at least get another um
another color
pen pens pens pens
okay let's see Christmas red and green
okay here's um now what I'm going to do
is
um uh I I want to uh draw lines between
these these dots here um and those those
lines are going to divide are going to
be U curve in a VIN diagram and the
curves are going to intersect only at
these dots um and so let me draw you the
curve that that's based on element
number four everywhere there's one of
these little uh line saying we've added
element number four I want to cross that
line so I'm going to go from here to
there
it's um where else do I go I add element
number four right here so there will be
a line from here to
here
um now there's got to be some somebody
else in the middle here where number
four is added so it's
here um so if I I just look for every
Edge where four is the guy who who is
new um here's three to four so here's
here's a case so I want to connect this
one here's here four gets in so I want
to connect connect there so I'll connect
from the from the dot to the middle of
the edge whenever the edge adds number
four uh here's
one and
um where
else one of these has to add a four this
is three
here and uh I'm almost done right um
this guy to here
and this guy to
here and then this one also comes
out there okay so that's a region that
everything on one side of the region has
a four in it and everything on the other
side doesn't I do that for three two and
one the same way I get a vend diagram so
that's that's the idea here so so these
chains of of subsets also lead to vend
di
yeah I'm missing
something the midle
oh
the counter
example what here no here this guy yeah
yeah you also have to do it right but uh
but if you do it right it's it's
supposed to It's supposed to work and
the and uh the lines will I mean the
lines will only cross at these at at
these Circle points because you know you
just draw the circle Point has to it's
in the middle of a polygon and so you
know just just draw that to the middle
of the edges and those lines don't don't
cross each other so so u u there will be
intersections so at the at the Circle
Point that's the that's a construction
and that works it gets Vin diagrams out
of these out of these chain chain
decomposition any question on
that okay now I want to show you one
more application and then uh open up for
questions um this one goes back
into into volume three wait well
actually I got more no no I got more oh
yeah
yeah um now before I do
this before I do this let me tell you
something that I find that I find even
more more exciting so that is that is
now I I got I got this this chain
decomposition but now I can associate it
with with
permutation uh of course um and so let's
look at
permutations and uh compare
I compare the
permutation um with uh uh
chains uh Now where's chains five
somewhere well uh the rule connecting
them is simple but be nice if I could
show them on the same
screen CH
five looks this looks
good okay so I got these chains that
we've been talking about now I also
heard every for every uh uh subset I I
can encode it by a permutation by first
uh numbering the on the ones and then
number the zeros and so so for example
here's my my uh 101 so so I so I I call
this 1 2 3 4 5 you know the one the two
ones are called one and two and the
three zeros are called 3 4 five and that
gives you this permutation 1 3 4
25 which is
uh 1 3 4 25
live these are permutations decomposable
two runs 1 3 10 10 where was 10
10 here that was the third guy down yeah
13425 all right you with me so every so
so so these are the yeah these are the
permutations that that have two readings
uh uh in the first line you lose because
there's no way to distinguish they all
go into 1 2 3 4 5 but uh everywhere else
these are permutations that let that
that need two readings you you know
there's um uh it's uh you can you can go
across and then then then again and then
you get the numbers one up to n um and
the number of permutations with two
readings is the so-called oian number in
o one which is 2 the N minus n + 1 it's
just exactly the number of elements that
are not in the first in the first row of
the
chain so so so that's so the number of
permutations is is right it's the number
of permutations that are you know it
it's equal to the number of uh of of of
subsets like this and we can encode the
permutation this way now the Curious
thing about this is that if you go into
the art of computer programming and you
look at the beginning of chapter 3 where
it talks about shad's Construction in
young Tableau and it's a there's a
beautiful
uh there's a beautiful theory about
inserting elements of a of a
permutation um systematically and and
and forming two so-called young Tableau
which are Arrangements in rows and
columns where it's increasing both
directions both in rows and both and
columns um and every permutation
corresponds to a pair of young Tau of
the same shape um and uh the um uh and
the nice thing is that once again this
this whole method of chains of substance
uh uh is is um is has a beautiful
explanation in terms of the ch's
algorithm in young T because it turns
out that the that that that that you get
two young Tableau so-called p and Q when
you're using Chen's algorithm and each
uh each U of the perations in a row has
the same Q
value so this is the you in other words
uh you can ENC and I I I drew the I I
drew the young Tableau here so so 1 2 3
uh in the first row and five in the
second row that's a young Tableau uh
here's another young Tableau you see uh
if you rows and columns are
increasing order and the um the same
thing works of course for um
permutations
um
uh on the six element sets and there it
gets more interesting so I put it up on
the on the screen if I can if I can find
it so here are the here's the example
for for the sixes so you know a lot of
more different kinds of of young Tableau
occur and the um uh uh see what time is
it now do I have time to to illustrate
this 5 it's quarter 5 okay yeah well I I
plan to to run over about only 15
minutes so I thought I would uh so so I
can show you this uh I I can show you
Shen stead's algorithm what I'm talking
about
um the here here's the idea
um uh get another sheet of paper
out and
um and suppose we
um um come on uh and it's it's a method
that works with any permutation but in
this case permutations are a bit simpler
because they they have only two readings
to them uh but but I do think my black
pen was working better than the red pen
so I'll try to find the black pen
again boy this this light really makes
me
blind okay
um let's take a let's take a um
uh a larger permutation because it'll
it'll show the it'll show the real
pattern that's will show what's really
going on although it might be too
complicated I don't think so so let me
take U an example uh it won't be as big
as bad as that that Pi example but let's
take suppose I had 0 0 1 0 1 1 0 up put
this a little lower than 0 1 0 0
0101 now what I I put these lower
because these are U these things get
boxed zero matches a one you know left
parenthesis matches the right
parenthesis and
uh and uh so um these are the three
elements underneath so when I encode
this as a
permutation I'll number the ones first
let me let me take another one I'll
change this to a one it's the same so
now um uh it's not going to matter what
uh in some ways what happens to Chan
algorithm so now the permutation that I
get from this I number the ones first I
get 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 then I number the
zeros and I get 8 9 10 11 12 13 14
15 now okay let's let's play Shen
algorithm the idea is you insert into a
tableau one one step at a time this is
p q over here P um and so I put eight in
p and the first step is never very
interesting because you just put you
just put the first element in and you
write a one here uh now the next step
nine nine is bigger than eight so I put
it in the first row
um uh Shen's algorithm we prefer to put
it in the first row if we can um and now
I since I filled that thing I want to
keep Q the same shape as P so I put
number two there now now Along Comes A
one and I and and I want to put one in
the first row but it's it won't fit at
the end so I so I put it where it fits
and I I bumped the eight down to the
second row so now Q is gets a three here
then 10 is next and so four comes here
uh two comes next and the two is going
to bump the nine down and and make a
five three is next that bumps the
10 um four fits fine in the first row 11
no
problem uh five is going to bump the 11
down
um uh here 12 fits here
13 and 14 so that's 10 11 12
whoops kind a head down 10 11 12 13 and
14 and then
six uh is going to bump
12 so uh 13 here and 15 will fit okay so
pretend you can see a 14 there and U and
then seven bumps 13 down here uh so so
what happened is that the q that the P
array is this 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 14 15 8 9 10
11 12 13 the Q array is 1
2478 um I claim that if you change this
if this is 0 or 1 0 0 1 1 0 1 one one
and you do the same thing you the the Q
array um stays the same and that's the
identif identifier so everything in the
same row uh everything that belongs to
the uh to the same chain of subsets
corresponds to permutation that shets
algorithm takes into the same
q and and one consequence of this
according to a theorem that I proved uh
oh 30 years ago now is that uh is is is
very curious um uh and that is that you
take any pattern of zeros and ones and
any you know like you know Pi um but I I
know the octonal
facts about
Pi so something like this and now you
you you you change uh and as see 0 one
0 um goes to 1 0 0 I might have this
wrong I might have to put the zero on
the left or one Z one can interchange
with a 1 1 0 uh you allow yourself to to
move to to Interchange zeros and ones in
this pattern but only if the guy on your
left is a on your right is a zero or the
guy on your left is a one or I might
have the the parody wrong on that it
might be the other way wrong but anyway
there you consider all the strings that
you can get from this one just by
repeatedly uh doing these uh these two
switches and the U the theorem says that
these are
exactly the um uh the subsets with this
many elements uh uh that that belong to
chains of the same
length so so so so you know this this Pi
belongs to a chain of length four and
you look at all the all the chains of
length four uh and you look at all the
things in the column that has this many
one bits in it those are exactly the the
uh the strings that you can get by by
interchanging these um uh making these
these local interchanges it's a curious
result I don't know if there's any any
use of it but uh it's it's true and so
you never
know now a question on
that okay now the the last thing was the
uh there's a connection to um
information retrieval uh so U right near
the end of volume
3 where it talks about retrieval
of with mult with with many attributes
there's a formula here which we might be
able to zoom in on and just just to tell
you about um it's an idea that it's been
around for 30 years saying by adding
some some redundancy to the way you
store uh things in a database uh you can
make sure that the answers to to U all
queries you want will appear
consecutively in the file um uh and that
you can get to them and there's and on
this page here there's a formula guess
we can't zoom in on it but there formula
eight on page 567 which says that if you
had four uh attributes AB b c and d you
could store them uh AB c d BC da a BDA a
c cadb CD there's six
permutations that you could store the um
uh you could store the attributes
according to those and then have an
inverted index uh to uh so that you
could look up and find out everything
Well turns out if you do this then then
any combination of 1 2 three or four of
the attributes and no matter what you
you say I want to find all cases you
know with where a is equal to 3 and b is
equal to or sorry a is equal to 3 and C
is equal to 7 uh those will all appear
consecutively in one of these six lists
and uh the uh this decomposition into
chains of subsets uh is really a method
that tells you how to do this in general
for General number of attributes and um
and you can leave out the short chains
if you're only interested in a small
number of of
attributes so
so that's one of the uh other
applications of of this idea which I
hope now you will find another
application of sometime uh so that you
didn't waste this
hour any other
questions
Y no uh it's very there's there's a huge
number of ways to make to make these
decomposition in fact the way they they
do their symmetrical ones for the case
of primes
um they they want to um uh uh they they
want to uh uh uh have have other
properties so that if you uh if you
shift everything to the right one uh you
stay then then your chain also
corresponds to another another shifted
chain um and uh uh uh yeah the number of
of ways to do the decomposition is huge
the the main point of this is that it's
it's e easy to compute you know it's
really I I doubt if there's any
if there's any easier way to uh to
decide uh for example just to find a
matching between the two middle the the
the sets of of things that are are n
minus one over2 elements with the sets
that are n plus one over two elements to
find a matching between those it looked
like uh uh very hard to find any
explicit rule that would do that and
this is the this is by far the the
simplest rule at that anybody body is
knows but the but the number of such
matchings is is probably
enormous there there's there's always a
big difference between what exists and
what and what can be computed fast and
really and really known you uh uh you
know we we know that uh um that
irreducible you know that that the
Primitive polinomial exist to generate
finite fields of all of all end but
there's no nobody knows an algorithm to
compute one for you know given
uh uh you just do trial and error until
you find one that turns out to be
primitive
y
yes yes
yes what does it look beautiful uh it's
uh uh it you know uh I I wish I could
say yes but I but uh uh it just looks
kind of uh computery to me
um so so uh that web page that I told
you about symmetric V diagrams is is a
beautiful survey of everything known
about about it and uh there's still uh
no really beautiful one for n equal 11
yet for example uh to look at the the
they they've constructed um they've
constructed them that are symmetrical
but they aren't what they call simple
and and and the ones that are really
nice uh one of the most one of the
reasons that these people started
looking at it is a is a kind of a
notorious conjecture that says that not
only is there a matching between these
two sets of of size n minus one and you
know n and n plus one when you have
a when you have two n plus1 elements and
you're trying to you know match the N
sets with the N plus1 sets uh there's
just as many n sets are n plus one sets
and uh and now this shows a matching but
uh there's also almost certainly a um a
hamiltonian path through them where you
know two matchings that that together
make a cycle so you can go from from n
to n plus1 to n to n plus1 and and you
hit everything exactly once and uh for I
was going to show you this beautiful
picture on N equal 7 where you can just
see them all uh in this in this nice
picture and you can just go from all the
all the three sets to the four sets and
the three and four and back and forth
and and there they are um uh it's
gorgeous but
um uh there people have shown that these
things ex that these hamiltonian
circuits exist uh uh in fact there there
are zillions of them um uh up to n
equals what is it 23 or 25 is you know
been computed and there's no problem
finding one um it's just to prove that
they exist uh uh seems to be impossible
uh as far as anybody knows it's just
like something like the goldach
conjecture where you know the um it's
goldach conjecture is almost
certainly uh true because it's true
because because it couldn't be false but
it's but but there's no uh there's no
proof for it it's the goldb conjecture
says if you have an even number you can
write it as a sum of two odd primes or
or two primes and um uh uh the number of
ways to do that is uh is huge and so so
so uh you know nobody believes that
there could possibly be a be a large n
for which all of the primes uh and N
minus the prime you know for n minus
Prime would just happen to not be prime
for all all cases of all of all primes
that's than n it's just uh this
inconceivable the probability of that is
is incredibly small and the number of
solutions is is huge but to find
actually prove that that that there
isn't such a funny end um may may you
know maybe one of those problems that
has no proof just just happens to be
true
yep well this was used in some IBM
software the guy Vincent Lum who
invented it was was uh at San Jose lab
uh I I don't know uh uh you know how
many people use it much you know you
don't need large end for this or else
you the N model replication gets gets
gets huge but uh but it's still um uh
it's one of the it's one of the tricks
that that that lets you think of you
know then you can approximate this and
get something that's pretty good by by
starting with the with this to Total
solution get something that has a little
bit of redundancy But but so I have to
look in several list instead of
one
the main idea though is that is is that
I hope you you get a little more insight
into interesting families of trees and
how how matching parenthesis might even
uh have something to do with uh
completely other things other parts of
uh of uh basic computer science ideas
than you ever thought of before so
thanks a lot Merry
Christmas